ECT which is a very viable and beneficial treatment for patients who are psychotic
and are very suicidal, I mean, I think it's well used and and nothing like they portrayed in the movies.
But that is based on a different
science. That is electric shock that is like a hurricane to the entire brain.
It wakes the whole brain up with with this one shock.
TMS is very specific it's targeting an area of the brain about the size of a quarter.
So it's not electricity that's administered its magnetic pulses.
Those magnetic pulses do in fact create a small electrical current.
But not the size of the current that is administered through ECT.
Transcranial magnetic stimulation does
not put wires on your head,
a small current is induced in the brain by
electromagnetism and crucially it
does not as generally used cause seizure.
It's a far milder form of stimulation, it's targeted to a specific place in the left front part of the brain.
It is not particularly uncomfortable. It does not alter consciousness,
and when used properly it has almost no side effects.
Crucially it does not require being admitted to a hospital.
Electric shock therapy
for severe untreatable depression is
still one of the most effective
treatments for anything in medicine.
And it doesn't look at all barbaric now.
The patient receiving it is under anesthesia. It looks like almost nothing is happening.
The problem with electric shock therapy is it still has side effects, its still terribly expensive,
and so it is not a perfect solution for vast
numbers of people.